[Music]
ben is in charlotte north carolina hi
ben welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and john i appreciate the time
and appreciate all you guys do sure much
what's up
um so my lovely wife and i we are saving
to build a home and purchase some land
and through conversations we've had with
realtors and builders
they recommended that we buy the land
first just to curb the increase in land
prices um in this crazy time so
the question that we have is we're
trying to save aggressively to do that
um but
knowing that we will probably purchase
land before we actually build the home
that extra money that we're saving
should we be paying down our mortgage or
should we just be saving all this extra
money in a savings account
um are you going you're going to buy the
land long before you sell the home you
live in
i don't i don't know how long um the
goal is to start building a home and
about um three years
so it's whenever the a deal comes with
the right property and the right amount
of land i would just save up the money
and buy the land
okay so save it all on a savings account
yeah and then just buy the land um
uh because uh you're the logistics of
what you're lining up the dominoes are
too far apart to knock the other one
down
in other words you might buy this land
sooner rather than later and then it
might be another year year and a half
two years before you even break grounds
what you're telling me
potentially yeah and if that's the case
you don't have a place to live because
you got to sell the house to get the
money out to buy the land and i'm not
going to tell you to borrow money to buy
the land
right and that's definitely not our plan
right and so if you put it all into your
house the only way to get the land would
be to sell your house or move into
apartment
yeah which we've done before and with
now we're gonna we're have three going
on four kids
we don't want to do it again yeah that
sounds less than fun
so yeah i think you just save up pay
it's a break even you're going to end up
at the end of the story with your house
sold and all the money that you would
have had in your house or it had in the
land is all going to be in the new house
anyway
yeah that's true so at the end of the
story it's all going to be piled over on
that one pile anyway so you're still
going to get there and you're not going
to add any debt in the process and so
um
you know until you actually do the
construction loan and that kind of stuff
if you do a construction loan so yeah
yeah i'm gonna just i think your advice
is good that you've been getting i would
just save and pay cash and buy the land
how many acres have you got um almost
seven okay man that's nice six yeah it's
good that's very nice it's good a little
wiggle room is a good thing